[موسيقى]
كان تساءلي انه يا سلمان العوده امامك
الضمير الاخلاقي للصحوه
انقذه
هذا التغيير يحدث
كانت اجابته مسجله كانت اجابته انه الجميع
اخطا في تلك المرحله هذه ترى اجابه خطيره
جدا لانه حينما تعمم الخطا
يختفي هذا الخطاب
التحتي الذي يهيا لهذه التنظيمات وانا
اربط ايضا هذا الكلام ترى كله توثيق يوسف
العياري في مؤسسه تنظيم القاعده الذي
وقتها قتل يعني بعد بدايه العمليات تحدث
في رساله وهو هارب وملاحق ويوجه خطاب
لسلمان عوده يقول كيف تتخلون عننا وانتم
الذين علمتمونا سمعنا اشرطتكم جالسناكم
حظر المحاضراتكم ثم تنقلبون الان علينا
[موسيقى]
عيسى العوشن وهو ايضا قائد اعلامي وشرعي
في التنظيم القاعده وقتل في
يوليو 2004
قال في رساله تابينيه مكتوبه ومنشوره ان
يوسف العياري قال له
حينما كان يوسف العياري اسامه بن لادن في
السودان حينما انتقل السودان او رجع هو
وقابل سلمان العوده قال حدثوا عن اسامه بن
لادن ونشاطه قال انني اتشرف ان اكون تحت
اداره اسامه بن لادن
[موسيقى]